[Music]
next i'd like to dive deep on a quest 2
exclusive
[Music]
as i mentioned earlier if you weren't
tuned into capcom's resident evil 25th
anniversary showcase last week
here's the scoop we're bringing resident
evil 4 to quest
2 later this year resident evil 4
originally debuted in 2005 on gamecube
and in the 16 years since launch it's
continued to inspire
games movies and the survival horror
genre
now the content of the game is not going
to change we wouldn't mess with such a
winning formula
but we also don't consider this a
traditional port
my colleagues at oculus studios are
working closely with armature and capcom
to rework the entire game for vr
every corner of the world is being
enhanced and remastered to feel
fresh and exciting to ogs and to new
fans alike
by ratcheting up the suspense as only vr
can
the most obvious differences between
playing re4 and vr
and on console is the shift in
perspective and interactivity
only on quest 2 will you be able to play
re4 from leon's first person perspective
and the touch controllers will allow you
to interact with the world in a
fundamentally new way from how it's
played on console
for example items and weapons have been
re-engineered to become
physical objects that players can
interact with so that you can pick up
things like
ammo keys and treasures as well as load
aim and fire weapons
in vr you'll also be able to switch
weapons by
grabbing them off your body instead of
going into a menu
and you can wield separate weapons with
each hand
even reforce famous menu is no longer a
pause screen
it's an interactive tool a ton of effort
has gone into making weapon interactions
smooth
satisfying and responsive including
two-handed weapons like shotguns and
rifles
let's talk about the movement system now
we didn't want the shift from third to
first person
to change the fundamental way leon moves
or collides with the world you'll still
move in first person by using the analog
stick
but armature has added a full upper body
rig on top of leon's character
to combine his movement with the
dual-handed interactivity
achieved with touch controllers if you
don't want to use the analog stick to
move freely
armature even added support for
teleportation
as well as room scale movement so that
you can explore the environment with
natural motion
and of course one of our top priorities
is to ensure the experience is
comfortably played
while seated and with a ton of comfort
options
at your disposal to try out as i
mentioned earlier
re4 debuted on gamecube 16 years ago
so you might be wondering how in the
world are we bringing the core systems
from the original
over to quest 2 well first it takes
passion
the teams at oculus studios armature and
capcom
are all longtime fans of the game who
are
accepting only the best results
and it takes time we've been working on
this title for
a couple years now and just carefully
and reverently making changes that will
make your experience feel both
fresh and nostalgic technically speaking
armature is using core systems from the
original re4
to drive gameplay and systems but
they've remastered art
over 4500 textures have either been
repainted or
uprezzed world geometry has been
adjusted to work in stereoscopic 3d
and enemy behaviors and attacks have
been balanced around the player's new
perspective
to increase mobility in vr they've also
improved support for running the game at
a higher frame rate
than the original 30 frames per second
and
fixed many bugs that the 60fps versions
of the game had
now while armature has adjusted a number
of things for vr
some things just haven't needed to
change character animations have been
faithfully converted to unreal engine 4
and remain untouched from the original
source material
and all cutscenes will be presented in
their original format
if you're a fan of the survival horror
genre like me
you've likely played or tried to play a
lot of scary games in vr
now re4 isn't known for being the
scariest in the resident evil franchise
but it is scarier and more suspenseful
in vr
thanks to spatial audio and immersive
interactivity
armature has manipulated aspects of the
original re for audio data
and have used it instead as 3d spatial
sound so when you hear noises like crows
voices and creaks you're going to want
to turn your head to see if there's a
threat
they've also made sure that audio
telegraphs from enemies
to indicate which direction they're
attacking from so where on console you
might have heard a gennado approaching
and
rather calmly press buttons to reload
and prepare a takedown
in vr you're checking your ammo you're
scrambling to load a mag
and if you drop it you're only adding to
the stress and suspense of the situation
by needing to physically correct your
mistakes you'll be
living in the moment carefully tracking
ammo and inventory
relying on your senses for success more
than you've ever done before
i'll leave you with this a huge part of
the re4
fame was the elaborate cinematics that
sell and tell the story
but once you come out of a cinematic in
vr and find yourself face to face with
the boss
the experience is totally different
[Applause]
i could talk for a lot longer about this
game but we've got to move on because
there is more to share today
but stay tuned for more resident evil 4
updates and lead up to its launch
on quest 2 later this year alright
now i'd like to share with you updates
on two of my favorite titles
because who doesn't love star wars